It's cold today,
look at this fine, fresh, and so so
6 This is a bit unmoving Tom's attack won't budge Let's use this to create a new star
While securing a space for water to flow
into the bra, I'm going in right now.
I'm looking at the one that ends at school with Japan in between, but don't tell everyone
[Music]
Then let's
evolve.
While I was checking all the time,
navy blue My
fighting ability is really high Is it really the library It's okay to be
this strong
StillーIn
terms of stats, it surpasses a seahorse Well,
you've gotten fatter, huh?
This amazing sharpness
ah ah ah
ran
[music]
Let's go
ah ah ah ah The
technology is working hard
Who's next to
me?